president Trump heads to Capitol Hill
today to push for tax reform with Senate
Republicans the president says he wants
to have the overhaul finish before the
end of the year but the clock is ticking
and the bill faces challenges in the
Senate
senators Ron Johnson of Wisconsin and
Steve Daines of Montana have both said
they do not support the bill in its
current form they are worried the bill
does not do enough for so-called
pass-through businesses the owners of
those entities pay taxes from their
business profits on their personal
returns Johnson says this covers more
than 90% of US businesses at least 7
other Republicans have not said how they
will vote they are concerned about
issues ranging from the impact on the
federal deficit to removing Obamacare's
individual mandate Republicans can only
afford to lose two votes Republican
Senator Rob Portman of Ohio is a member
of the Senate Finance Committee and he's
with us from Capitol Hill this morning
senator good morning thanks so much for
joining us this morning thanks for
having me on so it's just we laid out
two Republicans currently against the
bill how do you see things changing well
I think about 90% of the Republicans
have said they are supportive of it in
fact strongly supportive and then we've
got some folks who are still looking at
various aspects but they all want to get
to yes they all want middle-class tax
cuts they all want simplification they
all want the pro-growth policies they
you know in something that's complicated
there going to be differences but I feel
confident we'll come together you know
one of the interesting things is if you
address some of the concerns that some
of the senators like Ron Johnson have
which is to help these pass-through
businesses which account for 90% of
businesses in this country you do that
but then you add to the deficit and you
lose some of your Republicans who are of
course deficit hawks how do you find
compromise on that well you're right
there's a balance here but I will say
among those companies that are called
pass-through companies and it is the
majority of companies in our country and
they employ about 50 percent of the
people there are significant tax cuts
and there is tax relief because those
businesses also will be able to invest
more in their plant and equipment and
people though we hire productivity and
therefore more economic growth so that's
in there his question is whether it's a
balance in other words whether there's
parity with the multinational companies
that also get relief to be able to be
competitive globally so you know it's it
is a balance but I think in the end
we'll get there because overwhelmingly
Republicans and a lot of Democrats by
the way are very supportive of the
middle-class tax cuts the simplification
and just the the general focus here
which is how to get more jobs and how to
increase wages so how is this really a
tax cut senator for the middle class a
New York Times analyst found that more
than 13 million middle-class families
will actually be paying more well if you
look at the information that's objective
which would be the Joint Committee on
taxation and they're the nonpartisan
group up here it it's pretty clear and
there's been some analysis of this the
Tax Foundation is a good place to look
online or JCT gov of people want to look
online but if you're a median income
family in my home state of Ohio you will
get a tax cut on average of about two
thousand three hundred and seventy five
dollars and that doesn't include the
advantage you get from having again a
more competitive economy that many who
said that's several thousand dollars for
that same family as well every year now
for families that are living paycheck to
paycheck that's a big deal and by the
way it's progressive in the sense that
if you are a family of four two kids
making fifty thousand bucks a year you
get a thirty six percent tax cut on
average if you're making eighty five
thousand bucks a year you get a twenty
percent tax cut 165 thousand bucks a
year you get an eight percent tax cut so
the benefit is really focused on the
middle class and those who are in this
range of you know thirty to seventy
thousand bucks senator there is an
argument for corporate tax cuts and it's
that they will reinvest and pass those
savings on to middle-class Americans but
the Tax Policy Center said it could take
up to twenty years why will it take so
much time to put money back in employees
pockets yeah I think every economist who
looks at it says that we've got to
change the way we tax our companies
because they can't be competitive and
that some of the benefit is going to go
directly to workers now people disagree
some say that's 80% of the benefits some
say it's 25% of the benefit but you're
right that seem to go to families and
working families across America
I think it'll happen very quickly I know
there is a one-year delay in the
corporate cuts and there is an immediate
cut for families but I do think during
that time period because expensing will
be something that a lot of companies
will take advantage of immediate
expensing I think there'll be a lot of
investment
and that's what the economists seem to
say so I can't understand why it would
take that long because I think what
you'll see is immediate decisions made
by companies knowing they're going to
have this ability to be able to invest
more increase productivity and get wages
back up do you think it was appropriate
for President Trump to call one of your
colleagues senator Warren pocahontas
well you know they have a back-and-forth
that I'm gonna stay out of it it's a
long-standing I think that event
yesterday was an event to honor an
incredible achievement which was these
Navajo code talkers and should have
focused on that and you know what they
did in World War two is truly
spectacular and you know there aren't a
lot of them left and it was a time to to
pay tribute to them and honor them yes a
lot of people agree with you on that
senator we thank you for taking the time
but before you go are you as excited as
I am about Harry and Megan getting
engaged that's about time is all I
consider for Harry hasn't gotten the
attention you deserve
I can tell that seems like a nice guy I
can tell you love love - thank you so
much thanks guys great to be on with you
thank you very much